[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right people we are live on YouTube
we got a big one for you today one that
we had to do live I thought we needed
the live energy for this one because
it's big it's big and joining me sitting
across from me is a professor of biology
at Evergreen State College in Olympia
Washington
Brett weinstein welcome to the Reuben
report thanks we have a guy we have got
a lot to talk about man yes we do you
you are in the thick of it I mean you
are in the thick of in some ways what I
would say is everything that sort of
I've been focusing on for these last two
or two-and-a-half years
related to false cries of racism and
bigotry and things that are happening
with the left and the rush to judgment
and all of these things and we're going
to get to all that we've got a couple
video clips that we're going to show
about what's going on up there
but I thought the best way we could sort
of set this up is that for people that
have no idea who you are whatever green
state is all about all that let's just
do a little bit let's just do ten
minutes or so just talking about that so
first off tell me a little bit about
Evergreen State College because this is
a liberal arts college it's a republic
liberal arts college which is a very
unusual thing in and of itself but that
doesn't even begin to describe how
unique it is so the the most important
thing is that instead of having our
curriculum divided up into classes like
four credit classes as you would have in
most colleges we teach programs and
programs are full-time for both
professors and students so and they can
go on for two or three quarters what
that means is that we are able to
establish very close relationships with
students that allow us to understand
each person in the room as an individual
and that means that we can spot
individual blind spots we're not just
delivering education from the front of
the room and having people consume it we
are we have learning communities that
really function it doesn't always work
but when it works it's a marvelous thing
yeah and this is a place of
progressivism right I mean there is
there's a liberal bent here
progressivism and left this idea ideas
and things they're welcomed here they're
more than welcome to does a very
left-leaning campus
on the other hand there are lots of
students that are in traditional age and
so there is there is actually a fair
breath of opinion but the dominant
opinion in the discussion especially
amongst the traditional age students is
very left-leaning yeah and before we get
to all the craziness you yourself you're
a lefty you you liked and voted for
Bernie did you not I did like Bernie I
resonated with his message I did not
believe that if he won things would have
changed but I certainly supported him as
the best option that we had available to
us and I believed him as a person yeah I
would say it's a little too simple
though to say that that I'm a liberal I
think I'm sort of maturing out of that
and what does that mean to you well
let's just put it this way nothing about
my values has changed they're very
progressive my my objectives and what I
would like to see happen here on planet
earth are still classic liberal
objectives but my understanding of how
the world works has changed a great deal
and I have been working with a number of
people for several years trying to
imagine a very different mechanism for
making systems here on earth function so
I would say one of the things that we've
realized is that we need revolutionary
change and we can't afford revolution
and so figuring out how to get a
governance structure to to emerge that
is capable of doing the job has been one
of my primary hobbies you could say yeah
and it sounds particularly relevant now
because we have so many people that are
into revolution there's this idea of
hashtag resistance people want this
revolution but maybe haven't you know
thought out all of the things that
you're sort of working on and in fact I
think the the instinct is right people
recognize that we are in a very serious
circumstance and that the system will
not self-correct but what they haven't
realized is that the ability to
transition with the traditional
mechanisms of change has evaporated and
so they are they're chasing false hope
in my opinion and it's it's really
important that we stop doing that and
that we actually utilize mechanisms that
are capable of doing the job yeah from
those
mechanisms let's shift to the mechanisms
of biology because that is what you
teach just tell me a little bit about
what your passions are in biology and
the type of things that you're teaching
sure so I'm an evolutionary biologist
and I in spite of the fact that when I
hear the word theorist I want to roll my
eyes I'm an evolutionary theorist and
what that means is that I've been
building a toolkit since I was in
graduate school that is the tools
necessary to solve the problems that the
last generation of evolutionary
biologists wasn't able to solve so my
focus in graduate school became trade
offs places where the evolutionary
adaptive force can't push in the
direction of simple improvement because
it has to choose between two desirable
things and it turns out that a great
many of the puzzles that we can't solve
can be addressed if you look at the
tensions that exist between desirable
characteristics so I've studied
questions like why there are more
species as you get towards the equator
why we grow feeble with age why so many
species have elaborate sexual displays
that seem counterproductive to the job
of surviving so that's that's the gist
of it yeah and a lot of that stuff
actually does have something to do with
sort of the conversation we're about to
get into about race and everything that
you're dealing with right now do you see
some sort of connection there every
every connection whatsoever okay so
we'll put that aside so okay so let's
let's dive into it now I just wanted to
do a few minutes just so that people
know that you're a legit guy you're
working at a real school you are a real
professor and all that I want to start
with one other thing from your past
before we get into the present you once
left a Ivy League school because of
racism that you saw I thought that would
be the right place to start discussing
racism because some really horrific
charges are being leveled at you right
now and I thought it would be a good way
to start so can you just tell me that
story I can I'm going to shorten it
quite a bit it's a story I don't love
telling and it's complicated but the
gist is is this so I was at Penn this
would be high arrived in
1987 and my freshman year I was in a big
dorm and although I was not rushing a
fraternity and wouldn't have my one of
my good friends on my hallway was
rushing the ZBT fraternity and they were
having an event which they called a
mystery event that they advertised for
the big question mark and my friend
induced me to go to this mystery event
just because I wasn't likely to get my
homework done that night so I might as
well and I went and there was I don't
know an hour of not very interesting
stuff people watching porn in the corner
eating ice cream and odd odd things like
that and then is that what they're doing
at fraternity s back then I want an ice
cream I didn't spend a lot of time about
it now I'm an apparent okay okay so in
any case at some point the the lights
dim a disco ball I hadn't noticed
starts to spin and one of the fraternity
brothers comes out and announces that he
would like to introduce the audience to
his friend Leon and he wants you to tell
Leon that he's that you're going to take
care of his women and I started to get a
very sinking feeling of what was about
to happen women came out who were
apparently prostitutes black prostitutes
I should say Penn is in West Philly
which is a economically depressed
neighborhood largely black and the
fraternity in question was a wealthy
Jewish fraternity so these women come
out and it becomes clear that there's
going to be a striptease and I made one
of the bigger mistakes of my life and I
left I should have stayed because what
unfolded next would have been easier to
address had I been an eyewitness to it
when I got back to my dorm several hours
later my friend and another person had
been rushing the same for Kurt and he
came back into the hallway and they
described the events that had happened
after I left and they involved a
situation where Russia's were induced to
dance with these women on tables no new
there but then they had the fraternity
had somehow thought it a good idea to
purchase cucumbers and ketchup and they
enacted what was effectively I now
understand a ceremonial rape and I
thought that this was such a terrible
event to have taken place on a college
campus effectively sanctioned by the
fact that nobody was going to say
anything that I went to the school paper
and I tried to alert them to the story
and they were very interested it's a
very good school paper the daily
Pennsylvanian and they looked into it
and they called people who had been at
the event and they got seven or eight
different stories about what had taken
place that night including Scrabble and
Parcheesi and other things like that but
nobody would confirm the story and so I
asked them would it be all right if I
wrote an op-ed describing what I had
understood the event to be I wrote the
op-ed and you can imagine what happened
all hell broke loose and although there
were actually two fraternities that did
not come after me the rest of the
fraternity system went berserk and you
know it was a watershed moment the rest
of that year was a whirlwind including
death threats and another such things
eventually the the college was
embarrassed into having to investigate
the matter and they tried the fraternity
I I was actually asked to testify even
though I hadn't seen the event in
question and while I was sitting in the
witness the waiting room the brothers
including the president of the
fraternity came in and started coercing
witnesses so when it was my turn to
testify I mentioned that this had
happened fraternity was removed from
campus for I think two years and it was
forbidden to pledge a class I believe
that what happened is that the National
fraternity then bought them a house and
they secretly did did pledge class but
anyway it was it was quite a thing but
by the time it was over the ability to
be at Penn and just do college work was
it was not simple yeah
so you left Penn
I did leave pen I came back my sophomore
year but the place was was poisoned for
me at that point after what I had seen
and how I had been treated yeah well I I
bring it up because I think it's a good
way to preface everything we're about to
talk about and I can tell it's very
clear you don't enjoy telling the story
I don't think you're looking at yourself
as you're some kind of hero or something
you just did what you felt was right but
it is interesting because that's 20
that's 30 years ago at this point and
over the last 30 years you've done a lot
of things that have been to fight real
racism and you have a track record of it
and I think it's important because these
days when we tar and feather everybody
we seem to throw out everything they've
ever done and try to catch him on one
word they said wrong or one sentence out
of context or any of that so I'm glad we
got that out so now let's get to the to
the present sure okay so evergreen has
done something called a day of absence
for years now it sounds like it's since
the 1970s can you tell me what the day
of absence is because that's what got us
to where we are so it ever green it's a
yearly event and it's predicated on a
Douglas turner award he's a black
playwright a play that he wrote I think
in 1965 and the central conceit of the
play is that the underappreciated black
population of a southern town decides to
emphasize to the white population its
value by not showing up one day and
although I haven't seen the play
performed I've read a good bit of it and
chaos erupts because the black
population is so central to the
functioning of the town the play I think
is typically put on with black actors in
Whiteface which is interesting too
so anyway evergreen decided not too long
after its founding that I think it was
originally black faculty it's now people
of color more generally but black
faculty decided that the black
population of Evergreen should
ceremonially absent themselves to make
the same point that the play makes and
this has gone on until I arrived and
continued up until this year this year
so something changed this year so let's
and that's where this all begins so what
what change this year so basically you
had no
with that I had no problem with it
happen I don't find anything wrong with
it I have one concern about it which is
that a college is not a town and so when
the black population of Evergreen or
later the people of color don't show up
the college does not grind to a halt so
then I have a concern that it doesn't
quite make the point that it's supposed
to make but I have no problem with the
desire to make that point and I have no
desire with people deciding to to to
absent themselves that's all right so
you have sort what could be an academic
concern if they were supposed to be a
test that day or so some other thing but
not a concern about the specifics of the
premise of what these people write I
find nothing wrong with it okay and this
has gone on as you said since that means
you've been part of this for a long time
no problem what changed this year so
this year the organizers I understand
now from reading the school paper that
the organizers in response to Trump's
election decided to reverse the order of
things so that the organizers are people
of color
at least overwhelmingly the school paper
reports them as simply people of color
they decided to reverse the order and
have white people not show up to campus
and I thought about that when I first
heard it I thought I must have
misunderstood what was being said it's
possible that my reaction is different
than it might be because I'm Jewish and
alarm bells go off when I'm told I'm not
supposed to be somewhere but in any case
I thought I had misheard it and I put it
aside and then there were several emails
so it was announced that a faculty
meeting and then there were several
emails inviting people to commit to
participate but no clarification that
that was the structure yeah then what
didn't ask or tell because I think that
letter he's very careful about this yeah
there was no implication that white
people would not be allowed on campus
okay there was however the implication
that when this finally was described the
implication was that white allies would
be off campus and therefore there was
the implication that if you were white
and you showed up on campus that you
were therefore not an ally and that is
the thing that pushed me to respond I
did not like the implication that by by
the very
act of being there I was not aligning
with people of color that is that is not
my understanding right okay so there's
there's this meeting this is discussed
you then want realize that what you had
sort of feared was happening here was
happening here you then wrote a letter
now we're going to put the letter up but
I want you just to paraphrase that I was
going to have you read the whole thing
but I think that that may be a bit much
but we'll also post links to it down
below and it's out there on Twitter and
everywhere else can you give me the the
thrust of what your letter who is your
letter to and what was the thrust of the
letter I sent the letter to the all
faculty and staff distribution list
which does contain a fair number of
students I think there are few hundred
students who have a staff position of
some kind or other and so are on the
list so I sent it to that list knowing
that it would go to those people not
expecting it to be public but I was very
clear and I think I wrote very carefully
and what I said was that there is all
the difference in the world between a
population AB scenting themself from a
shared space and a population telling
another population to go away and my
point was that speech has to be free on
a college campus and that everybody has
to be free to be there I thought that
the point was so clear that it couldn't
really be missed and I was shocked at
how far off the mark the response was
yeah there was an overwhelming reaction
in public saying that I was effectively
attacking people of color privately
there was a good bit of support but this
has now become a pattern on our campus
we're especially surrounding any issue
that at least nominally has an equity
side that there is and under stairs a
nuanced understanding that can only be
discussed sotto voce and then there is
the public response which embraces this
one side giving the impression of
consensus but only if you're the person
that people are quietly approaching do
you know that there is no consensus
there's wide disagreement right okay so
there's a couple things we should just
clean up there so to be clear they were
not telling specifically white students
that they couldn't come but as you said
it would have the idea of then a white
student
going up you know effect this white
student would have been seen as the
enemy it's possible they wouldn't be
even known they would have shown up to
campus and been seen as a bad guy or a
racist or a bigot or a white supremacist
or any of that stuff that's number one
but you mentioned that when it got
public so you said that the letter went
to the it went to all staff all staff
and faculty also a faculty and there are
some students on that and that's how it
got to the college paper correct yeah
the college paper picked up on it from
there
I do want to say that the question of
whether or not it was or how okay it was
for white people to be on campus was
accidentally tested during the event so
when the day of absence arrived a friend
of mine a faculty member actually
somebody who's been with the college
almost since its founding Greek woman
misunderstood the intention and she
thought that the intention was for the
opening ceremony of the day of absence
to include people from all races which
would make sense to me and that then
people would go off campus and there
were 200 spaces in an off-campus venue
for particular events but those 200
spaces were not the limit of white
people even in the campus so anyway my
friend went with her students to the
opening ceremony of the day of absence
and it was held in the longhouse which
is an indigenous structure that we're
very proud of rightly on our campus and
she went in and apparently was
approached by one of the organizers of
day of absence and told that while she
could decide to stay that really this
event was not for people of her skin
tone and she decided on that basis to
leave and if she left apparently an
indigenous woman who is affiliated with
the longhouse in dismay apparently
turned to her and said the longhouse is
a place of welcome it is made that she
was being turned away and then she
talked to her students the faculty
member talked to her students and they
had felt very uncomfortable the way they
were being looked at so there is nothing
there was no requirement the only
particular person be any particular
place but there was extreme coercion
yeah I'm glad you mentioned the other
indigenous person there that says
this is a place of welcoming because
there is a sense amongst those of us
that talk about what's happening on
college campuses right now that the
inmates run the asylum and unfortunately
we know that the loudest and we're going
to show some videos of some of the
people that the loudest people get the
most attention then it seems like it's
everyone but a lot of it also is just a
culture now of fear where someone like
this there's probably many other people
like this but they're just afraid to say
no no it we know we know you're an ally
we know you're not a racist or whatever
it is you you are welcome here to show
solidarity with us well there is a
tremendous amount of structure inside
the larger the larger coalition of
people of color so within that there's
there are relationships that are not
transparent to the outside and every so
often one gets a glimpse and so there is
a tension between I think a very
aggressive vision on the one side and a
much more traditional vision of equity
on the other but the tension is not
visible and because it's not visible
there's this sense that this is a
two-sided issue yeah okay so we're going
to we're going to show two videos here
because there really are there are two
reactions well there's several reactions
happening here at once but in terms of
what's happening on campus there's the
student reaction and the academic
reaction and they're sort of connected
but they also come from very different
places so we're going to start with a
student reaction this is you I think
you're standing outside your office and
they and they know this is outside my
classroom is right outside your
classroom okay yeah the students came to
my classroom and started chanting when I
had divided my class up to have several
discussions and one of my students in
one of those discussions alerted me that
there were people outside the door
chanting hey hey ho ho Brett Weinstein's
got to go that doesn't happen every day
so yeah so I walked out to them I opened
the door they clearly knew exactly who I
was yeah and I said what's up and they
told me I should resign and I said would
you like to talk about this and they
said yes and I said okay let's go to the
fourth floor I got students on one two
and three they said no then we're going
to one two and three I came into the
building
really the whole building not just my
class and then they confronted me with
several of my students right there in
front of the classroom that we were we
were assigned for that day
okay so let's leave it right there we're
going to play the video and just to be
clear this was the first moment that you
realize this thing had escalated right
absolutely
okay all right so let's let's play this
one no it is debate means you are trying
to win dialectic means you are using
disagreement to discover what is true I
am NOT interested in debate I'm
interested only in dialectic which does
mean I listen to you and you listen to
me you want to speak all I think is not
about you I'm talking all about him I
turn the white crow pudding it's not a
discussion you have lost that what I am
talking about terms that serve the truth
those are the top you said some racist
[ __ ]
I don't know do I think the black
teachers in science are tardy you know
do I think they're targeted anywhere
[Applause]
okay
I do not believe that students of color
are targeted in the sciences here why
not maybe I misunderstand what do you
mean by targeted
oh wait a second to me targeted means
something different than what I just
heard you to find it Alice I do not
believe that anybody on our faculty with
intent special target what you gotta say
broken with my not targeting people of
color I'm sure I didn't hear you at the
beginning yes well yes damn pastor
you're probably break-in at the protest
if it will go to setting your email
marketing plan for blacks miss may I
answer that question okay Wednesday
first you are
first of all day of absence has been
here longer than I have I have until the
idea no first of all would you like to
hear the answer or not
[Applause]
listen II understand history could pivot
this hallway right now history history
could give it in the direction of the
values that you are what I will okay so
there's more of that video again we'll
put the link to that down below as well
if people want to watch the full piece I
guess the first part would be you were
you woke up that morning put on your
clothes as you normally do probably had
a cup of coffee went to work well you
can see how by how I was dressed that I
was not expected to end up on YouTube
you're your teacher did shorts okay I
biked in that way okay you biked to work
in shorts I mean you were just having a
regular day you had you had sent an
email there was beyond I mean I welcome
everyone to read this thing it should be
very clear just by listening to you at
this point there is nothing racist in
this email you are actually fighting
racism in this email then this happens
just purely what does that feel like
that moment where you realize that
something has just shifted what does
that actually feel like that's a really
interesting question I will say that the
experience in college all those years
ago prepared me for this in one way I
think I learned back then that one
should not be afraid to polarize and
that in fact if you're not polarizing
you may
maybe too timid in what you're doing and
that the really important thing to pay
attention to is if you are polarizing in
the correct way that is to say you want
the people that you respect to line up
with you now I do find something
troubling in the circumstance because
there are great many people who I think
in the end if they actually knew what I
do stand for would be aligned with me
and at the moment they think they're on
the other side because they haven't
looked carefully at the the policy
issues in question but it feels surreal
and in fact I've the whole that
interchange that you saw was very tense
yeah but it got far worse very quickly
by the end of the day it was it was
anarchy on our campus people were
including me we were literally being
stalked and hunted and it's a very it's
a very frightening feeling yeah I mean
you can even tell by your body languages
when you touch your head a couple of
times like there's almost like a an
exasperation of just like I cannot
believe this is real sort of and yet and
yet it makes sense that it's real
because this this monster has been
growing for a long time it has and it's
been it's been simmering on our campus
for a full year so before the day of
absence letter there has been a movement
afoot to increase equity on our campus
and the problem I don't want to drag us
too far into this discussion of the
particulars but the definition of equity
has never even been settled on so we
haven't there has been zero opportunity
to discuss the proposals that have been
advanced and so the proposals are very
clearly about equality of outcome which
I can't support the yes I know my
history and not about equality of
opportunity which I do support and yet
most of the people involved in the
discussion either haven't spotted or
haven't said that they even recognize
the difference and even saying that that
you are for equality of opportunity even
that to a certain amount of people that
are sort of caught in this line of
thinking that somehow has a racial
undertone to them even though what
you're saying is you want equality of
opportunity for everybody so everyone's
on the same plane
you write and you know I will say that I
I don't know I think we don't know but I
strongly suspect having studied human
history quite carefully and done a lot
of traveling and lived in different
parts of the world I strongly suspect
that most of the differences in access
to well being that human beings have
could be democratized that the simple
fact of having equality of opportunity
would solve this problem which I'm not
saying reaching equality of opportunity
is easy right but if you did it I
suspect that many of the differences
that we see between racial groups and
their performance would evaporate right
so okay so there you're you're being
screamed at they want you to resign they
want you to be fired they want you to
apologize there's plenty more in that
video that we didn't show
were there any voices there that were I
know that there were a couple people
that were your students that were there
that are still standing with you right
now but was anyone that was on the on
the attacking side was anyone saying
well maybe we misunderstood you or maybe
we were confused or was it just again
that the mob is always led by the
loudest voices so either they're afraid
to speak or maybe they don't exist well
um we should come back to the question
of why when people look at that video
they see so many white students that's
confusing to pay yeah but for the moment
let me just answer well have asked there
the pace of progress isn't what people
expect I did not expect to have
tremendous progress I was not responding
to them as I did it with the thought
that they were going to turn around in
that instant but I did think it might
plant a seed and that they would come
around over the course of days or hours
as they had interactions that didn't
line up with the narrative that they've
been sold that they would be forced to
think consciously about what explains
the fact that this person that we've
been told is a vile transparent racist
doesn't sound like one and you know I
think when I watched that video which I
don't love doing but when I watch that
video right I see hints of that and then
I had interactions later in the day
where I also saw hints of it but there
is also this overwhelming gravity coming
from the argument that describes itself
as pro equity
that that erases progress so even when
you partially reach somebody they get
reeled back in so quickly yeah all right
so let's get to the part that you
mentioned which is the the why are there
so many white seeds and in some respects
and some of the other videos that are
out there they actually seem more
outraged than the students of color well
I think I know the answer to the
question the answer to the question is
that there is a a syllogism within the
the movement at the moment that suggests
that because civilization is understood
to have been built on the backs of
dark-skinned people and that they were
not remunerated for this work that white
people are indebted and that therefore
when people of color ask for something
that white people should provide it and
what that has led to is a situation
where you have basically what I take to
be white anarchists that are acting on
behalf of a movement of people of color
and there's a there's a danger in this
that I'll share with you which is
there's a meeting later I don't know if
we're going to see a clip but there's a
meeting later in which things become
extremely heated in a room that at that
moment I had only one available exit and
hundreds of people enraged at me calling
for my head calling for the head of the
chief of police etc and there
their reaction is very dramatic I don't
I did not feel in that moment and I
actually never felt endangered by people
of color I don't think that they would
have physically harmed me but they were
speaking in a manner that that seemed
logical and I'm not sure that the white
anarchists that are doing their bidding
are clear on where the boundary is so
I'm concerned that there might be
violence of an almost accidental nature
here where people think they're doing
what they're being asked because they
owe and it results in somebody getting
very seriously hurt yeah when you say
white anarchists
do you think that these these kids in
this case that their actual advocate
like they're anarchists for anarchists
sake or that they actually think that
they're an important piece of the puzzle
to this like like is or is this just
virtue signaling at its highest order I
know you're not a psychologist but just
from the interactions that you're
experiencing I'm not but um you know the
thing about being close with so many
students is that I have a much better
window on the thinking amongst different
groups on campus that I might otherwise
I think most of the anarchists are
actually earnest and you know anarchy to
them is not an excuse for thuggery
although you know sometimes it goes that
direction they have an honest belief
that and I almost have some sympathy for
how they got here they're young enough
that they haven't seen any functional
governance in their lifetime and so they
have a sort of sense that government is
synonymous with this you know predatory
entity and that tearing it down has to
be a step in the right direction and so
anyway I think that you know they have
they have a sort of deep idea about what
world might be if only they could get
governance out of the way and they've
missed one thing and it's fatal to their
understanding but or it would be if they
knew it which is scale what they're
talking about is possible in a small
group and you just you can't scale it up
to hundreds or thousands or millions so
anyway they are they are thinking about
an alternative and they've noticed very
much what's wrong and I haven't
understood in my opinion as much about
what could possibly replace it yeah so
the other interesting piece of this on
the student side is the reaction from
some of your students because you've had
some students white brown black etc
you've had a bunch of students defend
you some publicly and some of that are
getting heat for that can you talk about
that a little bit sure um so I should
say my wife also teaches at Evergreen
and we have a huge number of students
from the fifteen years that we've taught
there that we stay in contact with and
so we have actually tremendous support
and there's a wide diversity
people in that group I have lost a
couple of students to this movement I
know of a couple of people who have gone
to the the other side which I don't
actually take I'm not happy that they
went but that it's only a few is
heartening because the penalty
especially for students of color the
penalty for being out of step with the
conventional wisdom here is immense in
the video I don't know how if people
noticed it but there's a woman standing
to my left and she's actually in tears
mm-hmm
and then later on in the in the meeting
that was so so dangerous later in the
day she actually spoke up and spoke on
my behalf to this room that was shouting
for my head as I'm you know I'm
receiving text messages from students
elsewhere in the room telling me there's
talk that I won't be allowed to leave
she stands up in the sit there was
literally talking kidnapped or something
absolutely I mean there's been some
crazy stuff here there was talk of my
being kidnapped I got a text message
from another student who told me that
she overheard a conversation that people
should keep mace hidden so this was a
very dangerous situation but anyway the
student of color stood up spoke on my
behalf was shouted down and then a woman
came over to her looked like she was
assigned to come over to her and explain
to my student why her understanding of
me was wrong so somebody who who doesn't
know me who's never met me was assigned
to explain to her why her experience of
me in my classroom was incorrect yeah so
all right so let's move to the to the
academic side of this because if people
think what they just saw was sort of
bananas from the from the student side
the academic side has not been any
better so first we're going to show a
video of another professor her name is
Naima la Naima Lowe and let's just throw
that and then we'll explain after
notation inside the library
we're pushing pants either way have your
own I think all right we're only showing
a tiny a tiny portion of that the
TriCaster might have free can you just
sort of explain what's going on there
yeah naima in that clip is and the clip
goes on for the air piece but she's
dressing down to other faculty members
who are there and telling them that
effectively they need if my
understanding of the clip is right she's
telling them effectively that they
either need to to go in and make
themselves answerable to this mob that's
been ruling the campus at that point or
go home that those are their only two
choices and she says that you know they
are the problem yeah now she has no
authority to do this she has no she can
say whatever she wants to them but I
mean they have their jobs and they're
allowed to express themselves however
they want so just sort of that it that
in itself it's encroaching on someone
else's freedom of expression it's
preposterous and I should say that the
same faculty member has accused me of
racism once very directly in a faculty
meeting and then implicitly in another
faculty meeting she said that the the
negative reaction to the equity proposal
that had been advanced was a racist
backlash in this faculty meeting when
she said that with the president of the
college and the provost sitting right
there I said you know somebody at some
point should check on the question of
whether or not I actually am a racist I
think you might be very surprised yeah I
was then told by the the chair of the
faculty that this was not the place to
defend myself and I said that's fine
where is the place to defend myself and
then Naima spoke up and said you
shouldn't expect a venue in which to
defend yourself the president Provost
set perfectly silently through this
interaction so that's fascinating that's
fascinating because I think for those of
us that are not in the world of academia
it's hard for us to really understand
just the sort of the little microcosm
that goes on there this little ecosystem
that exists and the rules that it plays
by and the outside pressures related to
donors and everything else that a school
has to deal with and even public schools
that
you know that they're all dealing with
these different things so okay we've
dealt with students we've dealt with the
academic side but the the administrative
side doesn't sound like they've been
very responsive here and in some ways
they've almost been culpable of the
atmosphere that's going on well I have
to speculate a little bit I'm not an
administrator and so I can't see inside
that world very directly but I have
spent a good deal of time in discussion
with administrators numerous Dean's I've
spoken at length with both the Provost
and the president the president I should
point out is new he came two years ago
and in my opinion what is taking place
at Evergreen looks very much like it is
student motivated but it is actually
primarily motivated by a partnership
between Naima and the president and that
has resulted in students I believe doing
tremendous damage not only to a college
that might be one of their greatest
assets in getting ahead in the world but
also to the values that were so hard-won
in the civil rights movement this
doesn't this does not make the movement
look reasonable or good and I'm very
afraid that they are undoing progress
that had already been won so I think
that's an interesting segue because as I
mentioned the top I mean I've sort of
been talking about this concept that's
happening on the left for a long time
and that they'll come and eat their own
and that these accusations of racism and
bigotry and everything else they've
become so over the top so the boy who
cried wolf that it's almost impossible
now to figure out when a real racist
exists versus someone that in your case
is actually fighting racism so for you
as someone that as you said on Tucker's
show on Fox News
I am deeply progressive that's what you
said this must be doubly even if you
would remove yourself from the equation
this must be doubly painful because
you're watching a movement that you
deeply care about cannibalize itself yes
and I will say there's one odd thing I
wasn't expecting here which is so I I
feel like the only thing that makes this
not a literal witch-hunt is that there
aren't literal witches right you're not
awake but this is very much that mine
that is unfolded here but in this case
there are actually three witches being
demonized on our campus and I'm one of
them the Chief of Police
Stacey Brown is another and Andrea
Siebert who is our our grievance officer
they've been demonized for other reasons
and the fascinating thing is that in
each of these cases the individual being
demonized is not just not guilty of what
they are accused of but the inverse of
it and it is it is shocking if it was
just me it would be lost in the noise
but to have it to see it repeated three
times is remarkable yeah so real quick
you mentioned is was it the chief of
police chief of police her name is Stacy
Brown Stacy brown so American we throw
this image up so there was an image that
at the later meaning that you were
talking about they had her come first
they didn't want her to come the
students didn't want her to come armed
is that correct and then they didn't
want her to come in a police uniform
correct well it's it's worse than that
so in police circles being disarmed by
somebody carries a special meaning it's
a it's a shameful thing to her to happen
and so the protesters demanded that she
show up in uniform without her right
right okay um she said no and the said
the administration had asked her to do
it and then the compromise was that she
would show up in plainclothes to this
very dangerous meeting on the fourth
floor but what you need to know I didn't
I didn't know her until she came to
check after the protest in the morning
she came to check on on my safety and we
met then and we've talked quite a bit as
I've asked her each day is it safe for
me to come on campus she'll say no it's
not safe to come on campus the
administration has stood down the police
force we can't protect you anyway I
think that has now changed but but in
talking to her she is the ideal person
for the position to address the question
of biased policing or police brutality
she's an evergreen graduate herself who
she actually hurt her desire is to
address bad policing she sees it as a
terrible offense and she wants to fix
the problem and the protesters
I think this is probably coming mostly
from the anarchists who have the idea
they in fact have an acronym
ACAB all cops are bad they are trying to
talk her into a confrontation that will
look good for them they're literally
they they will wink at her when she
enters a space and so anyway she's she's
a professional in the extreme and so
this isn't working it's not taking a
toll on her but she's not reacting to it
but it seems that there's a desire to
have a confrontation did you get the
yeah I think did we throw the image up
there if we haven't thrown it up we'll
get it up and if not if we'll put it out
there we go there so that's the image
that was being circulated of the police
officer the Chief of Police who came
plain-clothed to acquiesce to these
demands and now she's being treated you
know this is sort of this concept of you
know like when when there's a you know
Majin woz who's trying to reform his
that will be called a porch monkey or
something horrible or you know an Uncle
Tom when they'll talk to my friend Larry
elder and people you know so this
concept in a way that's prejudice that's
prejudging them based you want them to
behave a certain way just by how they
look and not by what they think well
I've started to wonder about the
question about why it's not just random
accusations
it's accusations that are the inverse of
the the person in question and best I
got so far is that what causes you to
end up in the crosshairs is some value
that you hold deeply enough that you're
willing to stand up for it and so in
order to shut down people who will
endure harm over a value you have to
level a deeply stigmatizing accusation
and so there's a way in which it is
exactly the people who are least
deserving of those those labels that
have to be silenced they have you have
to work the hardest to silence them and
so that they break out the big guns and
this results in this inversion of the
truth so that being said I think that
there's a lot of people who could have a
lot of professors out there that could
have been in the exact situation that
you found yourself and that probably
would agree with the
with the ideas that you're discussing
that would shrivel under this shrivel
under this absolute that would just see
that you know would have seen your
initial reaction immediately in that mob
said you know what I'm sorry I
misunderstood it I'll just continue
whatever and ultimately you'll just be
chipped away at for the rest of your
career until you just will say nothing
you are doing completely the reverse the
fact that you're sitting with me right
now you just did Tucker Carlson you can
do Joe Rogan on Friday I mean you are
taking this thing and staring it
straight in the eye and saying I'm not
going to do this where do you think that
comes from within you well what people
are asking you people ask me that all
the time for themselves they want to get
in the fight and they don't know what to
do or they're afraid of what the
repercussions will be whatever their
jobs are their families but you're going
No I'm going to do this there are two
things and one of them isn't so easy to
bootstrap it happens that my parents and
my grandparents did an A+ job raising me
in a way that left I believe no trace of
racism that's not to say I don't have
ignorant of what it's like to be black
or Indian or Latino of course I do I
also have ignorance of what it's like to
be an astronaut or be 6 feet tall or any
of those things but but there's no part
of me that doesn't care or is biased in
this way I think and so what I have is a
lifetime of experiences that say this
this particular epithet doesn't apply to
me and that means that when they come
after me with it it doesn't hurt
I'm angry that somebody would accuse me
of these things and I'm frankly shocked
that my institution would allow these
accusations to be leveled and do nothing
about it but I never for a moment
thought that in the end this would cause
people to believe it even if they
believed it for this last year all it
takes is stories from my past and it
becomes very apparent that this is just
it's a false charge yeah well that's why
I wanted you to illuminate that earlier
story because this isn't something that
magically appeared you've had a track
record of standing up for the right
things I would be remiss if we didn't
mention I had asked you we had spoke on
the phone about a week ago
we were trying to see if we could
arrange for this and I asked you I said
well well do you have tenure because you
know what level are you really putting
yourself out there
evergreen doesn't have tenure
specifically but can you just explain
with AB because that also is an
interesting choice to where your future
will be yeah we have something the
founders basically re-envisioned all of
the parts of the Academy that they
thought were that were deformed and they
they built alternatives to them so we
have something called conversion I do I
started as a visiting professor so not
even a regular professor I started as a
visiting professor I've now got I've
been converted so I'm not impossible to
fire but it's very difficult it's never
been used before right if I or someone
as far as you know as far as I know I
can't say for sure that that's true but
I don't I don't think so okay you will
note and I I think people who are
looking at the story and scratching
their head wondering what to believe
ought to think carefully about the fact
that I have not been censured I haven't
been suspended I haven't been fired
I believe the administration would love
to do something just to appease the
people who are calling for my head and
the fact that they haven't done it says
something about the fact that there's
there's no reason to do so could it
could it also be a little bit of timing
though because the semester is about to
end maybe they're just trying to not
they're not doing anything brave
obviously and by backing you by publicly
defending you they're not doing what
should be the right thing but that there
may be just waiting semester ends summer
rolls around people get distracted and
that the whole thing will just blow over
which again would go to that chip factor
that I'm talking about that it slowly
will be chipped away by doing nothing
but it could be a little bit of timing
here right could be you know I wouldn't
put a past them on the other hand you
know again the the the image from the
outside is deceptive and I have lots of
contacts from people in the
administration who are friendly to me
the Provost has called privately to talk
about the situation so I believe the
president would like to to eliminate me
because he he is running the college in
a way that's very embarrassing and he
would like to keep it quiet and I've
been left with no choice I've repeatedly
tried to
care of this internal to the college and
gotten no response and so finally at the
point that I'm unable to teach on campus
for my own safety I have talked to the
press but but in any case but we'll see
I don't I don't think they can fire me I
don't know what they would fire me for
and I think they will create a new
problem if they do right and and they
could just make it an untenable position
to be at that if they don't do anything
or embolden the people who are going
after you that September rolls around
and it would just be a position that you
wouldn't be able to be in well we're
already headed there because the fact
that the administration has not taken a
stand and saying you can't accuse people
of racism without evidence or something
along those lines has resulted in my
faculty colleagues turning on me now I
still have a good many friends who are
quietly supportive and tell me so but
publicly speaking I'm being challenged
and ever stronger terms and so it's not
going to be a very pleasant place for me
to teach come fall so that that private
support do you find it infuriating in a
weird way I've had a few people who have
been in positions like you where they
publicly been called racist when it's
not the case my friend Colin Moriarty
who was on here a few weeks ago sent a
tweet about a silly joking tweet about
International Women's Day and
International Business Times wrote a
headline about him being racist I mean
really but you know bogger stuff and he
was telling me that he the people that
were publicly or the people that were
privately emailing him and supporting
him but wouldn't do anything public but
that was more angering
than some of the other responses are you
feeling a little of that like you're
putting your ass on the line and why are
people only quietly you know as if
they're giving you like some little you
know they're giving you some scraps you
know I don't and and the reason that I
don't feel that you know I've thought
about it and I thought is this is this
cowardice but the stuff that is coming
back at me is so industrial-strength
that I can easily understand somebody
who can
bring themselves to risk having to end
their career in shame of a false stigma
of racism when I mean that's it's almost
the worst thing you can call somebody so
you know it would be strategically it
would be the right thing to do to say
yes they're being cowards and they
should stand up and there is a part of
me that would welcome it if they stood
up but I certainly understand why they
feel like they just don't know what they
will say in response to the charge and
so and so they're quiet what angers me
are the people who say nothing or worse
the ones who have embraced power and
done that in with the thought that they
know who's going to win the battle and
therefore they're their bread is
buttered on a particular side so for
example we've gotten to a situation
where Naima who you saw
shouting epithets at other faculty
members when she speaks in a faculty
meeting and alleges that there is
intense racism on our campus that needs
to be addressed the next thing that
happens this happens over email to is
she is reflexively thanked by multiple
people even though what she's saying is
in many cases file yeah so just the the
the thanking of the real racist is so
troubling and just for the record well
let's I want to throw up one other thing
she tweeted out and I am a tweeted out
basically a threat to your wife your
your wife Heather is a professor on
campus also and this is really a direct
threat that she put up where we'll put
it up and it's this sort of I mean oh
lord could some white women at Evergreen
come and collect Heather Heather hangs
racist ass Jesus I mean that that really
is a threat you're saying someone do
something this woman is on campus
someone do say this is a member of the
faculty they haven't even countered that
from the administration have a well so
it's almost unbelievable so I saw that
on her Facebook page and I took a
screenshot and I carefully purged her
identifying information and I shared it
with my faculty colleagues over the
email list and I you know basically
pointed out I said a faculty member is
threatening Heather and I was shocked
that the response from Naima was that I
had misunderstood the the post that in
fact collect has a special meaning in
black vernacular I searched for that
special meaning and I could find no
evidence of it which doesn't mean it
isn't true but this is where this
question of the right of people of color
to to boss white people around
especially in an environment where these
anarchists are doing the bidding of this
coalition is so dangerous even if it is
true that collect is somehow a piece of
black vernacular that I'm not aware of
nothing says that the white anarchists
know that and that somebody isn't going
to attempt to collect my wife for I
don't know an inquisition
yeah when you've already heard that
there were rumors of a kidnapping and
all kinds of other stuff well the police
in fact told me on Wednesday that day
after the protest of my class they told
me they had they called me I said are
you on campus I said no they said don't
come to campus the protesters are
searching car to car and asking for
identifying information of the occupants
they're looking for what they say as an
individual and we think it's you I mean
the level the the ineptitude or the
negligence I guess of the administration
is off the charts here to me that's the
big the student thing we know this has
been growing on campuses for a long time
but when a when a professor is under
that type of threat and police don't
come to campus as a professor and the
administration refuses to say something
I mean I don't know how much more
evidence you need of a deep corruption I
honestly cannot believe it the number of
things that I have seen that I thought
well now they have to act and then they
have failed to do so is is unreal and
the fact I mean George bridges our
president continues to capitulate to
demands that are leveled by these
protesters when it is explicitly said if
these demands aren't met there will be
violence so I realize he's in a tough
predicament but to to continue to throw
us under the bus under those conditions
can only make this worse
what do you make about where you're
finding allies right now so you know
obviously when I heard about this and I
should mention by the way that you're
Eric Weinstein is brother who's a former
guest of the room important has become a
good friend of mine and and he's done a
very public defence of you which I think
has been really wonderful so you've
gotten some interesting Jonathan Haidt
publicly defending you
Nick Christakis from yell is for me I'll
also formally from you yes right right
so you've had a whole bunch of people
publicly defending you as I said you're
going to go on Rogan in a couple days
but I saw you were getting some hate
because you went on Tucker Carlson on
Fox News did MSNBC reach out to you did
CNN reach out to you did NPR reach out
to these you have to post reach out to
you did the daily blah blah blah reach
out to you did salon reach out to you
did Fox reach out to you I can keep
going here right you see my point what
do you make of that
without your allies that it's seemingly
that the free speech non hysteria allies
are all centrists or certainly more
probably more to the right of you in a
lot of respects or at least in the
classical liberal sense where is the
backing on the left what you yet you're
deeply progressive that's what you said
on Fox News when's the last time that's
been said on Fox News that's what you
said you got Tucker even said you you
must devote appear later he said I voted
Bernie and I'm deeply progressive right
well so I think what's going on is this
I think we've reached a moment where
thinking has become very simplistic and
I see this on my campus all the time
when there is a a nominally gay side of
a story or a nominally equity oriented
side of a story there is no nuance
whatsoever applied there's no
extrapolation about whether or not there
might be something that pushes in the
other direction
and so what that results in at the level
of the press I think is how exactly do
you process the story right if I'm if
I'm what I say I am which is anti-racist
then what is the meaning of these
protests and the demands for equity at
Evergreen so they think they literally
don't know how to report it yeah
it's crazy alright so here's what we're
going to do I'll go over here for just a
sec we are I'm going to do about two
more minutes with Eric right now we're
just going to put a little a little bow
on this I think and we're going to do a
live QA we're going to do it on super
chat right here on YouTube so you guys
if you throw in a couple bucks your your
comment gets bumped up we'll ask Brett
some questions directly and and we're
also gonna do that for people in patreon
so if you just comment in the feed right
there we'll get to your questions so
we'll do that in about two minutes so
let's just did I miss anything here in
the setup to all of this where now we're
going to kick it to the audience is
there anything else that you want to add
or that I might have missed in the
context of this well there is one thing
that I think is very important I'm
getting a flood of email like nothing
I've ever seen the unanimity is amazing
and it is across the political spectrum
it cuts across racial lines every known
fault line as United and sorry I haven't
counted them but it's at least 500 to 1
in support so that tells me something if
I look at my campus reaction the faculty
are closer to unified against me with
you know people quietly calling to
support and things like that but the the
public's response to this has been a
uniform and extremely supportive so the
difference between the way this looks on
the campus and the way this looks to
outsiders is profound there's a moment I
think it's a little bit past the video
that we showed earlier where you were
trying to calm the kids down I think you
were saying something to the effect of
this could be what were you saying this
could be a watershed moment or they
don't be a I think what I said was
history could pivot in this hallway if
we could hear each other yeah and I
thought that so it's a beautiful phrase
first off but it really showed that you
were sort of again five minutes before
that you didn't know is going to happen
but you were really you know within
yourself at that moment do you think
that that's where this could be at that
you could be thrust into something that
all of us in this space have been
looking for reason you know this ball
has been rolling down the hill and
picking up steam and some of us have
been sort of fighting it and but you
know a lot of people are just getting
lost in
the in the spinning do you think that
this truly could be a moment because
it's so ludicrous what's happening here
there's no I Oh des of evidence of the
charges do you think this could be a
moment that pushes it a stir
answer me that and then we're gonna take
a quick break we'll go to questions yes
I do
and the trick in order to make that
happen and I really do want it to happen
in order to make that happen the story
has to stay out of the narratives that
are supposed to explain it on both left
and right in other words it has to be
kept in conscious space where we don't
just push it to some sort of known
animal so I think that could happen I
hope it does happen I'm afraid that some
some momentum is going to get behind
some version of this that's going to
cause it to be dismissible and then it
won't and we'll who knows what the next
episode will look like yeah all right
well here's what we're doing we're going
to take literally a two minute break
we're just going to stand up and stretch
you want you want a shot of vodka or
something I'm going to think that
privately and then we'll take your
questions on super chat and on patreon
you can just comment in the feed right
there hang on two minutes we'll be right
back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
alright guys we are back with Eric
Weinstein biology professor last time
what Brett well his brother is Eric
Weinstein this is Brett Weinstein I got
the Weinstein yeah but I said why not
Weinstein that's pretty good come on now
get it right we are back with with Brett
line side from Eric from Evergreen State
University is a biology professor there
if you caught what we did in this last
hour he's involved in really a big mess
with false accusations of racism and
just so many of the things that we talk
about here related to free speech
related to a lot of the problems with
the left right now and and with so much
what's happening in society at large so
I thought I asked see questions for an
hour let's open it up to the audience so
we're taking questions live from you
guys on super chat on YouTube and from
patreon so I thought this was a nice way
to start and it's barely it's barely a
question but I will let you comment on
it and this is from super chat it's
wonderful encouraging to watch quote
live as individuals on the Left awaken
to the dangers of radical left ISM I see
that as a pretty clear statement I've
been trying to warn people about this
the difference between liberalism and
leftism do you feel that your awakening
to something that that maybe you didn't
see that much of just in the past couple
years
um I what would it be personal now you
know no I I would I would put a
differently I would say that we we all
need to level up and the fact is there's
nothing wrong with liberal progressive
values in fact I think they are the
right values the understanding of how to
accomplish those values how to how to
elevate them is it's not good the
standard left
progressive vision is not rich enough to
actually function that said I don't see
a functional version on the right either
and so I don't know how to say this
exactly but the more the older I get and
the more I see the less I think there is
value in the left-right dichotomy and
really we all need to go up
we need to find a new level and new ways
to to describe what differences we do
have about how to accomplish what ought
to be universal goals yeah I have a lot
of video game people that watches the
show so I think the idea of level up
level I think will not claim will
resonate with people at this one was
sort of interesting on patreon I don't
know that it's directly specific to the
way you teach but I think you'll get the
thrust of it do you feel like you helps
create this environment by teaching
these kids that colleges are racist and
the system oppresses all minorities I
suspect that you specifically didn't do
that but I think what they mean is sort
of that that leftist ideology is so
predominant in colleges I do not feel
that what I've been doing contributed to
this in the slightest in fact quite the
opposite so what I do is I arm kids with
incredibly powerful tools of reason and
I use evolutionary biology as a
landscape in which to teach critical
reasoning but really what I'm doing is
teaching them to think in a very careful
nuanced way when I look out at these
protests I'm struck by the fact that I'm
teaching at a small college and and I
have a lot of students and I don't
recognize the people who are challenging
me and in fact students that I do now
tell me that they can imagine if they
had not encountered me and my wife they
might have been sucked into this but I
think this again is a place where we
have to recognize that science is
actually the cure for low quality
thought that science I've been saying is
the ultimate [ __ ] detector and
really my message to those who are
protesting is that equality will be
reached much more effectively if you arm
yourself with the best possible tools
for getting there and those those tools
are contained in the sciences yeah I
love how we all come from this or come
to this from our own discipline so I've
been pushing the idea that the cure for
this is true liberalism and using logic
and reason and real liberalism of
live-and-let-live that's really the
answer but
you come at it from a scientific place
and using that as the basis there's a
lot of fertile ground for us both to
work on this from there so I love that
this is interesting from super chat the
church I volunteer for turns a blight a
blind eye to this issue I've brought it
to pastors but I'm completely dismissed
roughly 95 percent of our congregation
are left what can I do
I've seen people socially lynched along
with myself so I think when they're
saying turn a blind eye to this issue I
think they mean the issue of false
accusations of racism well um so I've
been doing something for as long as I
can remember which is and I actually did
learn this from Eric who taught me that
the most important things you need to
learn are often the province of people
that you wouldn't ordinarily be talking
to and so in the environment that I
teach in and in my life outside I very
much enjoy trying to cross gaps that are
supposed to be uncross upon so for
example when Jehovah's Witnesses come to
my door
I very frequently I mean I always talk
to them I I will often invite them in
and I'll tell them look you got your
work cut out for you here that you're
talking to an evolutionary biologist but
but let's let's see where we can get to
yeah so when I leave them a couple
minutes sometimes a half-hour well so my
point is that actually I learn a
tremendous amount from talking to people
that I'm not supposed to be talking to
and that has that has been a very useful
skill in the classroom as well but what
I would say is in the context of the
church figuring out what the mindset of
people who are ignoring this is so that
you can get to it and figure out you
know the trick is to get them to rise to
consciousness if you're getting a
reflexive answer it's coming from a part
of the mind that isn't conscious and
once you can get the the mind to throw
an error it is forced into consciousness
and once you throw that error it's
forced into consciousness you can have
all kinds of conversations hmm this is
from patreon this is interesting because
it did strike me when I watch these
videos where do you think the extreme
use of profanity by the student
protesters comes from there you know
it's because it's not just yelling for
yelling sake
but there there's a ton of profanity in
it is that just a motion I'm not sure I
guess I would say there is king so the
fact that the the accusations that they
level have no content to them tells you
that they are actually tactical that
they can turn you into a straw man and
that doesn't mean that they've failed
just because they're incorrect about you
as long as the stigma attaches and so
what I would say is we all process
cursing differently and that's why
Tourette syndrome is what it is is that
somehow we store those words differently
and that means that when you face them
maybe the brain realizes that that's an
indicator that you're you know you're
only a couple clicks away from violence
and so for the person who will stand up
if you start hearing those words tossed
at you it kind of says hey cool it so my
guess is whether the protesters know
what they're doing or not it's a
tactical issue yeah this is interesting
from super Chad for people outside of
the u.s. to what extent do you feel that
what's happening at Evergreen is
symptomatic of a general trend in US
campus culture we touched on this a
little bit but but you're in a very
specific version of it do you think that
this is this is the trend this is the
real thing that's happening right now
well I've been talking to my wife and my
brother about this and I think the real
issue is that in the 60s and 70s a new
type of scholarship emerged around
critical theory and at the moment it's
critical race theory at the front it has
reorganized the fundamental nature of
the Academy because it it is built from
an incompatible set of assumptions from
the sciences and the other disciplines
that work forward from from assumptions
to conclusions and because of that the
two can't really be in terribly close
contact they have to be
compartmentalized away from each other
in a normal university setting but that
also means that they don't they can't
well science is not in a position to
check critical race theory and so
critical race Theory has reached some
conclusions that
believe are not valid and it is now in a
position it is set in a structure strong
political position to dictate those
terms to the sciences that we are seeing
a kind of reversal of fortune
so I don't know if that answers your
question but yes I would say that
Evergreen is having a very particular
version of a pattern that is being seen
across the Academy in this country this
I don't think this is a question but
somebody may be doing something very
nice for you
it says reward free speech heroes
GoFundMe Brett wines the Weinstein free
speech your fans back home are proud of
you Brett so I don't know if that means
they maybe created a go fund me for you
but I guess you'll find out this one I
don't know that you're going to want to
show your cards so easily this is super
chat at what point would you quit
working at Evergreen if this continues
and what would you do afterwards
you don't have to answer that in any way
that's good yeah create a bigger problem
at the moment I mean I have to tell you
since Tuesday morning at 9:30 I feel
like I'm living in some kind of odd
dream I mean yeah parts of it are
nightmarish parts of it are reassuring
but in any case I haven't even really
been able to think carefully about what
this means it's it's a hard enough issue
just to even figure out where whether I
can hold class on campus or it's going
to be in the park again
yeah I may have missed what this is
referencing but what was the question
this is from patreon what was the
question being asked of you regarding
the physics department are you sure what
are you sure what that's referencing was
the question that was being there there
may have been something in that whole
melee with the students well I can't
imagine me for one thing we don't we
don't have departments so there isn't a
physics depart
oh this is this is interesting and I'd
be happy to facilitate this have you had
any contact with Jordan Peterson you
know Jordan Peterson up I got it I sure
I know of his work I admire him greatly
he has retweeted a couple things and as
soon as things died down I certainly do
intend to get in contact but I haven't
talked to them yet I will be glad to
facilitate that if you'd like right uh
here's another one on patreon what can
we do to help Brett and his supporters
that may be the million dollar question
yeah for everyone else right well that's
a very interesting question I guess I
would say a lot of what is going to take
place
has to do with the narrative as its
going to develop and in fact the program
that I'm teaching right now is focus
very heavily on the importance of
narratives in getting people to alter
the way they function so I would say the
danger of this story getting sucked in
to some known narrative at which point
it becomes useless is great and so in
conversations online keeping people in
their conscious mind as they engage this
so that they can actually tease apart
the different aspects of it and
understand them as they really are
rather than as the cartoon version that
would be very useful yeah and to me that
seems so real because I don't know how
much you know about my sort of political
evolution or where I came from but you
know when I saw that that whole crazy
night my audience knows is because I've
told it a thousand times but that crazy
night of Sam Harris on Real Time with
Bill Maher in the fight with Affleck and
gross and racist and all that and I saw
the way this guy was being slaughtered
that forced me to get involved it just
got me to a point of saying I can't take
it anymore
and it got me there and now there are
people that defend me from some of that
so it's just we need we need more of us
and well that that is that that's an
excellent answer and I think the thing
is imagine everybody is somewhere on the
spectrum of courage and imagine that
when somebody crosses over and can't
take it anymore as you've just described
and they speak up that creates cover for
the people in the lair right below them
and if this is to become a turning point
having those people who know better
emboldened by the people who've stood up
before them that is the way it will turn
well you got it from your brother you
got it for me
you got it from Joe and you get and you
got it you got it for many more many
more you got it from any more because my
my iPads blowing up over here
this is interesting on on super chat
Bret were you previously aware of this
anarchist element within progressivism
what are your thoughts on why
progressivism is the foothold for these
anarchists I think that's interesting
cuz you've addressed this sort of the
sort of white allies of this that really
are more anarchists did you realize that
they were a piece of progressivism as a
whole which obviously you really
like you know I've understood that this
anarchist threat was important and
needed to be taken seriously since
occupy that's the first place I really
understood what it was and I didn't
necessarily expect it to function this
way I have seen things in this last week
that are so overt with respect to a
racial hierarchy that is the inverse of
the usual hierarchy but nonetheless an
overt racial hierarchy on a college
campus just shocks me every time I think
about it but once once one wraps their
mind around the fact that that hierarchy
is going to emerge in in overt form it
makes perfect sense that that the white
anarchists would show up as they do
another one on super chat has the left
which for so long has used the epithet
racist liberally when attacking the
right now painted itself into a corner
is this just the beginning or the
culmination I guess we'll sort of find
out where your adventure goes with this
I suspect you hope this is the
culmination but well yeah I hope we've
hit bottom is what it is and really well
actually maybe I'll just say this it
looks to me as I look across the
landscape of forces that almost every
coalition is an unholy alliance between
two things in the case of this equity
movement most of the people in the
equity moment are interested in equity
as their objective a small percentage of
the people in the equity movement are
interested in in reversing the
oppression they don't know that there
are two different factions because until
you reach equity they are pushing in the
same direction but they really want
things that are fundamentally different
from each other so my hope is that every
coalition will look at itself and the
Honorable people the adults who are
willing to give up some of the sacred
stuff that surrounds their movement will
join together and basically a coalition
of the reasonable would be an excellent
thing to come out of this this is what
would jump back to patreon for a moment
this is good because I mentioned to you
before we started that I was recently at
a
a conference over weekend where there
were 400 college professors all talking
about how do we how do we fight this
stuff and this is before sort of all
this had bubbled up publicly to you so
the question is basically the thrust of
the question is basically about donors
like is that really the answer here that
you've got to hit these donors because
ultimately these forces if they realize
there's no money in this will we'll stop
doing this stuff so in which contexts
are you asking about the donors you're
talking about the college context yeah I
think in the college context that really
hitting the donors that if you can't
make headway with the administration
which at this point is being grossly
negligent it seems in defending you in
not defending you that maybe if you go
for donors in generally in these schools
that that's the way to effect change
well we're autumn line is the bottom
line we're in a very difficult position
because we're a public college and we're
hovering at the border of fiscal
coherence so what I would say is I don't
know how evergreen gets out of this
because this is obviously damaging to
its reputation and we can't afford that
I suppose I hope that somebody a donor
that is in line with progressive values
will step in and save the college and I
don't know if that's conceivable or not
but there is something there very much
worth saving and frankly you know even
these protesters stand to gain a
tremendous amount if the college can
write itself find its original values
and you know move forward towards the
you know the noble version of equity
rather than the the one that they're
pushing towards well said this is
something that I've thought about from
super chat I believe that the u.s. is
the largest export of culture my biggest
fear is that we are radiating this
polarity across the goal of course
across the globe what are the
implication that's a great question and
this has changed so much in our
lifetimes because of the way the
cultures are now linked together so this
is a tremendous danger which is that
good ideas can spread but so can bad
ideas I will say I'm starting to get
lots of mail from overseas and
don't know what it is that caused that
to happen but I do think I'm ashamed and
saddened that it's my institution that's
causing it but this is a wake up call
and maybe the point is having seen this
over social media people will not
capitulate to movements that are pushing
towards towards illiberal ends so this
is super Chad this is slightly off the
of exactly what we're talking about but
why do you think it's acceptable for neo
Stalinists say Marxists and communists
to wave the hammer and sickle flags in
our society when flying the neo-nazi
flag rightly gets a disgusted reaction
do you even want to have you've got into
enough yeah yeah there's a winning
answer yeah yeah well again I let's just
say this I think we if we can get you in
a lot of different troubles then it
could defray the main dress yes what I
need is I need everybody United with me
as the common enemy um yeah maybe I will
just leave it at that okay fair enough
all I can do is promise to ask the ones
that I'm asking I can't force you to to
answer anything I'm not sure if you'll
know about well let's not do that one
cuz I don't I don't know about that one
yet I Bret I fully support you and it
may not feel like it but the support is
there what would you suggest we do to
resist these social justice warrior
actions so just just for the regular
person I think we sort of addressed this
already but is there anything else just
for the for the average person that
doesn't want to publicly do something
maybe but ya realize that most of them
are good people who are confused about
something and have gotten caught up in
in something bigger than they are that
isn't headed in a good direction but
they are reachable I mean you can even
see that in the clip of me reasoning
them and the more of us that are
actually compassionate about the fact
that there are real problems that need
to be addressed and they haven't been
addressed and maybe this is the thing to
say the oddness of this protest at
Green is hiding a more difficult truth
we have desperate inequity if that same
protest that same intensity of protest
was directed at inequities in our system
of jurisprudence it would make a lot of
sense what I think has happens that the
university system is being attacked
because it's a soft target not because
that's the place that is spreading all
of this inequity and so it's incoherent
in the context of the university system
but really it's just pointed at the
wrong thing so if one goes into talking
to social justice warriors with the
mindset that they're making it up that's
I think sadly partly right they're
making it up at some level about the
university system but they're not making
it up entirely the inequities are there
they're very important and they're
crippling so give them the benefit of
the doubt with respect to the fact that
there is something that they are
responding to and then talk to them
about whether or not they're in fact
pointed in the right direction
yeah I love that look you can't force
them to sit down but it's why I always
say the road to hell is paved with good
intentions these people who I often have
huge disagreements with I don't disagree
there disagree with or deny that they
believe what they're saying is right so
we have to at least give them that to
then be able to do this this is a good
one from patreon can we get even five
thought leaders on the left to publicly
denounce these regressive trends and
help us create a dialogue on the better
way that I think this is particularly
interesting because it's related to sort
of you being on Tucker and invited to be
on Fox and nothing from MSNBC or NPR or
Huffington Post or any of that other
stuff that that the left I think has
been so cowed by these words of racism
that they just won't they won't stand
with you publicly even if they know that
they should so the leaders just simply
would rather throw you to the wolves by
by doing nothing what does this left you
speak of haven't seen that so long yeah
yeah yeah I mean where are the people
that should be forget you for a moment
but just as these trends have happened
for a while where is the broader left
that should be standing up for free
speech and for all of these things I
don't know it is dropped below the
threshold of coherence for some reason
I like that unwell I don't like the idea
but I like the way you said it let's see
this is a super chat someone said please
ask era please ask Brett about the high
art of communication it will be worth it
please ask grandpa thing ah the high art
of communication very good so it got
there so yes it did it had to connect
with a particular so one of the people
that I've been working with is the wrong
term but collaborating with in trying to
envision how civilization might be
altered so that it actually functions
and doesn't put us all in jeopardy as
guy named Forrest who has come to the
conclusion that the problem the primary
problem that we face getting to a a
functional system is that people don't
know how to talk to each other anymore
and he's been working on a system for
essentially bootstrapping schools is the
wrong term but events that would cause
people to develop the capacity to talk
to each other in an ever deeper fashion
and having done so the hope is that what
will emerge from that is really much
tighter language that most of us because
we share a basic language speak as if we
know what we're being heard to say but
in fact when you get right down to it
anybody who's doing high-quality work in
some corner has had to narrow the
definitions of their words and when they
to such people get together there is
intense confusion until you've hashed
out those those differences so the idea
is the high art of communication is
actually a necessity if we are to be
able to talk about the issues we face at
a sophisticated enough level to really
address them as an interviewer I should
probably be doing a little more research
on this I think you're not so funny as I
accidentally called you Erik once and it
keeps almost coming out of my mouth but
basically you throw a beard on Erik and
you get them but slightly more you know
form-fitting haircut and I've got a
marker just before uh Brett with the
responses on evergreen in Berkeley how
can conservatives find a voice on campus
today what are your thoughts on what the
fur
escalation maybe by either side I think
the first part is interesting because
you're not a conservative but I suspect
you wouldn't have a problem with more
conservative voices being heard well I'm
you know I must say as I said at the
beginning of your program I'm sort of
abandoning this continuum because I just
don't think it's useful yeah it is
amazing how much more likely at the
moment it is that if I sit down with
somebody who says they're a conservative
that we're going to have an interesting
productive conversation and it's not
because I'm a conservative but it's
because I think if you're conservative
you've been challenged in a particular
way for so long that you've had to deal
across aisles before whereas the left is
more insular so one thing I would say to
whoever asked that question is consider
whether you are in fact a conservative
to me a conservative is somebody who
wishes for the structures in place to be
preserved as they are and I can't
imagine how a reasonable person looking
at the structures the way they're
functioning now would find themselves in
that situation so is conservative is
that label doing you a favor
just a word itself doesn't sound cool no
you want to get young people you can't
use the word conservative right why are
we this is super shot as well why are we
letting these children have their way
won't rewarding bad behavior only
perpetuated I think that's a
particularly good one because it's sure
it shows what the position of the of the
of the professors is at it's like they
don't want to be treated like you are
now treated so they do let these kids do
things that they probably should well
that the kids can do whatever they want
but I mean they don't challenge them in
a way that you should be challenged at
college I think this definitely applies
to the way the administration has
handled the demonstration it shouldn't
be negotiating based on threats as far
as I think these kids is also a little
too simple you know there's a lot of
structure within even the group that's
protesting and you know there's a video
that you didn't get to hear there's a
video in the middle of the day on the
day that I was challenged
in which the protesters are some of the
leaders of the protests have corralled
the president I think he's you know I
think he's essentially literally a
prisoner
my understanding is he wasn't even
allowed to go to the bathroom alone but
they're talking to him about their
demands and their I believe they're
mistaken about a number of things but
they are totally understandable and one
can relate to them and I had the feeling
watching it wow I really wish I could be
in that room that the president is
blowing this because he's negotiating
with them rather than this is the
ultimate seminar this is the place where
we can have this discussion about are
the things you're asking for a
reasonable what would be reasonable what
are the real problems and he didn't do
it seeing has as there's an interesting
theme here and I think they're they're
going to this because you're a person of
the left it's a super Chet seeing how
liberal arts colleges seem to be
indoctrinating students with mainly post
modernist ideas what needs to change to
have an open and honest education I
think you've already well you hit this
right let's just say that that's not
that's not the right portrayal the
sciences especially at Evergreen are
extremely strong what they are facing is
an overthrow and the the key is not
putting the post modernists in a
position to dictate terms to the hard
sciences and the other fields that are
earnestly interested in inquiry you know
be they history or whatever so that's
interesting so you can oh not that you'd
want this necessarily but you could
almost let them play in a certain area
for a while and maybe that's what we all
did for a long time but now you're
seeing it encroach into the hard
sciences and that's where the real
threat is the chickens have come home to
roost is what it is now well I'll put
you on the spot with this one this is
patreon do you think that after the
sewer deal is taken care of the
president of Evergreen should step down
for his slow response to de-escalate the
situation on your campus ideally I think
he should step down on Tuesday of last
week I can't imagine I mean it is so
insane that he allowed the four o'clock
meeting
that nearly boiled over into violence or
the chief of police literally told me
she thought that she and I were in
severe danger in that room to have
allowed that to happen and not to have
to shut down the college is clear
negligence that put people in danger of
life and limb he should clearly resign
yeah you're like this one as a biologist
see we were going to get to biology here
somehow as a biologist do you see the
actions and events like this and others
as an evolution or the evolution of the
human species that's a good one hmm and
can it be both at the same time perhaps
well I had that part okay how about this
human beings are a very unique creature
and if you think about what you know
about human history you will realize
that human beings are a species that
without changing substantially in form
has switched from one niche to the next
as they've moved across the globe so we
are a creature that is capable of
reinventing ourselves very seamlessly
what has happened here is that the cues
that say it is time to reinvent
ourselves and to behave in a different
way have not hit their mark and so I
believe what's happening is somebody has
not somebody but some force has
prevented us from evolving as we would
normally do into a new and more stable
phase and so what you're watching is the
boiling over of a system that has
outlived its usefulness in the absence
of the natural the natural change that
should replace it has here we go
professor why is that is there any
improvement or conflict that you could
imagine coming in the next decade or so
with society at large Oh with a left or
society at large so you are hopeful in
some ways that this if this is a
watershed moment that things could start
turning well I'm hopeful on two fronts
one the Academy needs to get its footing
because no matter what your view of the
way forward is we need an entity that's
capable of figuring out what's
true so let me just say this if the if
critical race theory wins the battle
with the sciences the sciences will
reformulate somewhere else they will
have to in order for society to function
and then critical race theory and it's
postmodern partners won't be able to
survive alone you can't have a
university built on that alone so I'm
hopeful that this will cause people to
wake up and that when it does the
sciences will be shored up and we can we
can return to work at a societal level I
think we need to realize that all of the
mechanisms that have functioned to
produce positive change in the past are
not going to work in the present context
and we need to start thinking outside
the box you got 15 minutes more we'll do
a full hour of QA can you hang for 15
okay all right so we're going to do 15
minutes more so if you've got some more
super chats or you're on patreon let us
know right now this thing's growing fast
here this is super chat as a rising
senior starting to look at colleges I'm
equally baffled and horrified at the
extent of affirmative action I obviously
have a horse in this race but you think
I'm justified or biased now
interestingly this person didn't say
with their races we can you have to do
something but what do you make the
question well I mean it's an odd
question I'm I'm noting the term
affirmative action in there and I must
say I'm not against affirmative action
I'm not convinced that the structure is
the right one in other words we all know
that it has problems and that it creates
stigma for people but I believe some
structure is justified and that we ought
to be earnestly searching for for what
it is so that's about the best I can do
this is a good one on super Chet how do
you reconcile your views on equity and
the horrors of all equity based
ideologies over the last two centuries
this is sort of that I think that road
to hell is paved with good intentions
thing no I mean I think that person is
synonymous with equality of result if
that person thought about equality of
opportunity I'm equality of opportunity
is in fact something we all ought to be
able to agree on right if you're but
does it always get morphed into equality
of outcome are there real instances
where I know we can fight
for equality of opportunity all day long
and plenty of other people do obviously
but it seems like it always gets morphed
into equality of outcome I think it's a
special case of capture and that really
one of the largest problems maybe the
largest problem that humanity faces is
that in the modern environment capture
comes for everything sooner or later so
the fact that equality of opportunity
gets captured by equality of result is
one more instance of a malady that we
have to address generally this is
patreon what percentage of university
students do you estimate condone or
participate in the silencing of non
leftist opinions and even facts on
campus I don't know that you have a like
a hard number on that but you're just
with your experience right now what do
you think I would say it's a much
smaller percentage than people realize
that these protests are so overwhelming
I would say almost all of my campus has
some sympathy with the protests I mean
you know as I do I'm I'm not I'm not
interested in preserving privilege and
there is privilege I don't think it's
happening at the college and so I would
say the vast majority of students are
not participating in the protest nor
would they support its successes but
there are sympathies because there are
real problems this is interesting is
there research that the hard sciences
are being pressured out of performing do
you know of anything right now that
they're they're getting hit on well I
don't know that that's exactly how it
works
I think what it is is it works through
taboos and stigma that there are certain
things that one can't study and in fact
you know one of the things in the letter
that I wrote that caused such a stir was
that I was offering to give a lecture if
people wanted it on day of absence or at
any other time on the the evolutionary
view of race and people immediately
assumed that they knew what lecture I
was planning to deliver and that it was
you know it was basically scientific
racism when in fact it would have been
quite the opposite lecture so what I
would say is the idea that we can't go
to certain places because we know
that they are weapons of oppression is a
stifling world to work in and it's the
taboo we need to work on are things
really as bad as they look on college
campuses no yes
um yeah I unfortunately they are would
you have said yes three weeks ago yes I
mean that says something right there
this is super Chet how do I answer my
Christian family when they say there has
never been a gain of genetic information
from one generation to the next and is
the geologic column an actual thing
outside textbooks at the second part of
that went over my head yeah I mean you
guys are exactly what they're talking
about I listen to the first part yeah so
this is a very important point it's
going to be a little bit hard to convey
in this format but there was a a
spectacular failure in the study of
evolution at the point that DNA came to
be understood so Darwin of course knew
nothing about genes because he didn't
didn't have the tools to know at the
point that first genes were discovered
and then DNA was understood to be the
genetic material the mechanism was so
elegant that people assumed that is
Darwin's mechanism rather than that is a
Darwinian mechanism and what that did is
it removed the ability to understand how
a creature like a human being
evolves because human beings we do
evolve genetically but that's not that's
not the primary way in which it occurs
the primary way in which it occurs is a
replacement of the software program and
so we still have not dug ourselves out
of the hole and built the toolkit that
can address those questions properly so
I would say yes
human beings have not altered in a major
way in well it depends how major a way
but we have been like we are for
something like two hundred thousand
years but that doesn't mean that we
haven't been revolutionized over and
over again by the replacement of one
software program with another hmm this
is from patron who do you believe is
most responsible for the oppressor
oppressed dynamic that these students
seem to live by
I'm responsible for creating the dynamic
is that what you would guess that that's
what the question is oh boy well the
answer isn't a fun one the answer is
that human beings are genetically
predisposed like every other creature to
favor behaviors that cause the exclusion
of alternative genetic spellings that's
what every creature is about and what
that means is that human beings like all
other creatures when an opportunity to
spread genes is the result of a kind of
oppressive behavior that that is favored
and so one of the things that I've been
trying to explain to people is evolution
has given us some gifts and it's given
us some hazards one of the hazards is
that people are wired to be more
generous with those who are more closely
related and that that happens at every
scale and so the same force that causes
a mother to love her offspring causes
one population to go to war with another
and we have to allow ourselves actually
to be inconsistent and to favor maternal
love as we reject war mm-hmm
so my basic point is this is not a
simple problem we have to realize that
evolution is playing a role in creating
human behaviors and that what it is
pointing us towards is not always
honorable and by the way I think in the
video that we showed there's a further
portion where you start explaining that
and even even saying that was eliciting
a response to people that somehow you
were pushing some sort of racial
identity on people or something right
well I think the the danger is that once
people start hearing about genes and
exclusion they think that you're
advocating for it rather than saying
actually this is this is a warning we
have this dangerous mechanism built into
us it doesn't have to be triggered there
are lots of times when people are not
you know you sit around the dinner table
with people who aren't closely related
to you and you're not constantly
thinking about whether you can steal
their stuff so
we can turn these mechanisms off but we
have to be deliberate about it and you
know really the ultimately we have to
build a society in which children
develop in an environment that
reinforces the standing down of those
mechanisms I like this because it gets
right to mechanisms what legal structure
would you remove or replace to provide
more equity of opportunity so if we're
going to really get this equality of
opportunity there is there anything that
you would remove or replace that exists
right now well that's a very big
question I would say the ways in which
power reinforces itself are many and
they are insidious they show up in
places where they're not labeled in a
way that you can recognize them so I
would say we would have to actually you
would have to go through all of the
mechanisms that allow society to
function in order to discover things
that hobble so anyway I think it's too
big a question to answer in a short form
but it's a very important question
fair enough we've got five minutes left
Brett I feel like too much focus is on
students in these situations eighteen to
twenty rolls across the nation are not
organically spawning these ideas how do
we confront the faculty who perpetuate
this so we talked about that a little
bit that you know the students are being
led in a way they're not just magically
coming up with these ideas what's been
your best technique with the faculty
member maybe that's you know teetering
either way well unfortunately and this
is why I think it is this issue that is
boiling over in this particular fashion
the stigma is so intense that there is
no way for almost anybody to challenge a
faculty member wielding these epithets
so unfortunately the rules have to be
structured such that those who stand up
are protected by their colleges in other
words they have to be penalties for
trying to stigmatize somebody and
unfortunately we're in an environment
where if anybody proposes such a thing
they will be stigmatized and the the
reforms won't occur yeah that's
interesting because you haven't said
anything about asking or calling for the
woman I'm sorry her name one more
naima to to step down but the proof
because really it falls on the
administration and the president not
necessarily on her she's she said what
she believes whether you like it or not
well get this the first time that she
came after me i went to the president of
the college and i sat down with him for
a couple of hours and we talked about
the situation and she is in fact on the
equity council and my feeling is anybody
who is so blatantly biased in a racial
fashion doesn't have any business in the
discussion of equity and I told the
president this and I said she has to be
removed from the equity Council in order
for the equity Council to have a prayer
of doing their work and he said
effectively yes but that's the Provost's
job and so I went to talk to the Provost
and he agreed he said it was the
president's job and so privately there
was agreement that she needed to be
removed but publicly there was nothing
since this seems to come out of the
humanities do you think that the
difference between scientific method
meaning empirical falsification and
critical group theory accelerates
political division could you repeat
that's a big that's a big one there's a
lot there and we've only got three
minutes left so we're going to do one
more reference one since this seems to
come out of the humanities just this
battle that we've been talking about now
for two hours do you think that the
difference between scientific method
meaning empirical falsification and
critical group theory accelerate
political division I have to parse this
a little bit yeah that I fully
understand it I think I got it
I would say it results in inevitable
division because the assumptions of the
two mechanisms for inquiring are not
compatible the assumptions from which
these two modes proceed so what I what I
would say is it this is a place actually
the in invoking the humanities is the
way to address this the humanities are
not inherently postmodern the humanities
can be addressed with the same or
similar assumptions as the sciences and
when you do that actually you get very
powerful stuff
like Guns Germs and Steel for example
and so really the point is there's a set
of assumptions that really can't be
allowed to persist within the university
system because it is destructive of all
of the other work that the system can do
and that's really the solution to the
problem yeah
all right there's a whole bunch here
that we could keep getting to I suspect
this is not your last appearance on the
Rubin report whether you like it or not
all right I also I want you to be able
to speak when you have Rogen in a couple
days because you can do three hours of
this with him so I asked you at the end
of the the original interview if you had
some final thoughts but now after seeing
just sort of the theme of some of these
questions and everything else that we've
talked about is there is there any last
thought that you have and then yeah well
we'll step outside and go walk my dog
I'm alright take a breath of fresh air
yeah I guess I have one thought we have
either an indefinitely large number of
problems or we have a small number of
problems and an indefinitely large
number of symptoms if you're caught in a
narrative that's a familiar one it's not
rich enough to address the problems that
we face and so what I would ask is that
everybody should look around in their
own corner and figure out what
assumptions are here that I haven't
checked that might be getting in the
road to understanding what other people
are talking about yeah I was going to
send people to your Twitter at the end
of this is that where you want me to
send them or show yeah why not where
else can we send them no that's probably
the place for now I'm probably going to
put up a channel at some point it's at
rat weinstein on twitter that's with 1/t
it's usually with tooties what is what
happened to that other T my parents were
reasonably strapped for cash when I was
born so alright well it's been an
absolute pleasure youyou obviously know
you have an ally in me I think this this
thing that you're on sometimes people
just get thrown into this and and it's
truly an honor that you chose me as the
first person to sit down and and talk to
you about this stuff because we need
each other and I don't mean just we but
I mean all of us anyone watching this
that gets it we need each other and I
think maybe this will hopefully be a
seminal moment that we got some of the
the wins back on our side so I
appreciate you taking the time this is
an honor for me too and thanks for for
having me out all right thank you guys
[Music]